GOOD AFTERNOON -- RULES
COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY JUNE
TENTH IS HEREBY CALL TO ORDER
ADVISER AUDIO VIDEO RECORDED
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS IS ALSO
BEING TELEVISED A MATTER SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY
CUNNINGHAM THEIR CORREO FLORA
HERE GRAYSON KAMLAGER-DOVE
HERE MAIENSCHEIN HERE MATHIS
QUIRK SILVA HERE RAMOS RIVAS
YEAH WICKS LIVING HERE WE HAVE
A QUORUM AND WE HAVE A CONSENT
AGENDA MISTER CHAIR OF LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY REMAINED AN ITEM
FROM CONSENT SB TWO SEVENTY SIX
I'M GOING TO SHOULD BE REFERRED
TO BOTH HEALTH AND OKAY --
SUBURB SB TWO SERVICES WILL BE
ADDRESSED SEPARATELY -- IS --
MOTION A MAJOR CONSENT CALENDAR
SECOND BY HIS WORKS SECOND OF
OUR MISTER CUNNINGHAM AHMED
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM
AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE FLORA FLOOR
I GRAYSON AND I KAMLAGER-DOVE
HI KAMLAGER-DOVE I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS MATHIS
I PERSONAL BUT I BURKE SO BY
ROMANS BY RAMOS I RIVAS RIVAS
AYE WORKS WICKS I LIVING LIVING
PROCESS OKAY VERY GOOD --
THAT MOTIONS PASSES OUR MOTION
REFERRAL OF SB TWO SEVEN SIX
TWO THE SINGLY TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE SO MOVED MISALIGNED
SECONDED BY MISTER IS LIVING
YEAH I MUST BE QUITE LIKE NEVER
-- THANK YOU FOR THAT
CORRECTION -- SEVEN FOR ALMOST
TRANSACTION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM KNOWS
FLORA LARA METAL GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE HI
KAMLAGER-DOVE I AM MAIENSCHEIN
MAN TRYING NOT VOTING MATHIS
MATHIS NO QUIRK SILVA NUMBER
BURKE SILVANO RAMESH RAMOS
I RIVAS RIVAS AYE WORKS FIVE
WEEKS I LEVINE LEVINE I THE
MOTION FAST AND THIS WILL SERVE
AS A DRUNK THANK YOU VERY MUCH